no han pasado ni dos semanas desde que
daniel ortega fue reelegido en unas
cuestionadas elecciones presidenciales
la oea desconoció los resultados y en
respuesta el gobierno nicaragüense
planea retirar a su país de este
organismo en una sesión en la asamblea
nacional 83 de los 87 diputados
autorizaron la petición sin embargo el
proceso debe ser aprobado por el
presidente una vez más esta organización
ha pretendido violentar la soberanía
independencia y autodeterminación de
nuestro pueblo cuya última acción
injerencista puede manifestar que las
elecciones generales celebrada en
nuestro país el pasado 7 de noviembre
carecen de legitimidad democrática hoy
siendo intereses de traidores de la
patria y a personeros de la casa blanca
de los eeuu de américa y sus
subordinados si bien las instituciones
estatales están dirigidas por el
gobernante frente sandinista de
liberación nacional varios se oponen a
la petición de la asamblea nacional
después
y salirse del organismo continental no
creo que sea el sentido
los nicaragüenses bueno la mayoría de
los nicaragüenses más bien este
partido oficial del gobierno por otro
lado el presidente estadounidense joe
biden ordenó vetar la entrada a su país
de su homólogo nicaragüense a su familia
y el resto de miembros de su gobierno
asegurando que los actos represivos y
abusivos del gobierno de ortega y de
aquellos que lo apoyan obligan a eeuu a
actuar
ortega se impuso en los comicios del
pasado 7 de noviembre con el camino
electoral despejado después de que en
los últimos 7 meses fueran arrestados 7
aspirantes a la presidencia y tras la
disolución de tres partidos políticos